a Massachusetts man has been toiling in his
backyard on an epic passion project for seven
years building a 38-foot wooden sailboat using
boards cut down from his own property with a
possible launch now just months away Brook Silva
bragger decided to check in on him and he joins us
now good morning to you good morning Dana well in
2015 Steve Dennett had two college degrees but no
real career after a stint teaching he was working
at a Climbing gym but since childhood he'd hung on
to a nagging dream of someday building a boat from
scratch and sailing it around the world well on
his 30th birthday he decided to do it cashing in
his life savings and the life he knew seven years
later for Dennett and those around him so much has
changed you can see what really what we've been
building wow I mean it looks like a boat it looks
like a boat yeah and every stage of the process
that's what people say ah it looks like a boat oh
it finally looks like a boat oh now it looks like
a boat when the process started Steve Dennett knew
nothing about boat building but making one from
scratch he estimated back then would take him as
much as 10 years when we first started and I was
like I'm gonna cut down the trees and build a boat
and everyone's like you're crazy and it was always
what about significant other what about kids what
about career what about what about what about what
about yeah yeah and then we would talk to people
who are in their 70s their 80s they would go do it
you have the stream go do it what are you waiting
for do you think it's because they couldn't do it
anymore or because why do you think the difference
in the generations I think they understand what a
lifetime is and what you actually have the time
for and what you're going to look back on and
wish you had or hadn't done so in January 2016
Dennis so that guy's a white oak with no Gray
the beard yet started cutting trees how was
that it was good that was good made Splash you
his friend Alex creeder agreed to help
and make videos how did they go today
when when it was done they'd go sailing together
filmed as the logs became boards and as those oak
boards were steamed down she goes until they
could be bent into their new shape you have
a matter of minutes to get them bent into the
boat before they Harden and become non-playable
again and then you just fire in the are they
rivets or rivets yep so there are square copper
rivets and we couldn't find them big enough
anymore we made a machine to make the rivets
the plan to fund the project was for Creator to
make these videos to drum up donations through
a crowdfunding site so the first Keel bolt is in
and yesterday we bolted up the stem here but for
a long time the money didn't come for two years
Dennett and krita had to keep their day jobs and
scrounge for supplies for the lad we needed 12
000 pounds total where do you find 12 000 pounds
of lead you hunt for a year and a half so where
do you go hunting for lead I literally would ask
every single person that I had a conversation with
do you know where I can get some lead hold on a
second if you ask a hundred people that question
how many have a positive answer for you one or two
but sometimes you strike cold or lead I talked
to a woman and her daughter and they're like
actually yeah my husband has a tire shop so we
went and picked up 2 000 pounds of wheel weights
figuring out how to pour our own Keel has been a
trying part of this project the video of melting
that lead and pouring it into a keel went viral on
YouTube and acorn to Arabella caught on donations
in YouTube ad money let Dennett and creeder quit
their jobs and build full time the attention also
brought more and more help paid and mostly unpaid
people like Dennett drawn to doing something
exotic and hard for reasons they struggle to fully
explain KP polea was supposed to start college but
took a job here instead that's it the confusing
part is you had already tried boat building well I
love boat building but then you left boat building
correct because it didn't pay enough that's right
but this pays much more than that no so that's
where I'm trying to understand that's fair
that's fair it's going to start coming down
a little bit okay nine-year-old Aaron Wayans
volunteers every Friday I'll try my hardest
this was his first time using a Disc Sander
here 76 year old Joe Damon arrived with four
Decades of experience on the Bridgeport machine
that happened to be donated just before he came
by how do you find out about this my wife spotted
it because it's in Granby I said our Granby
or Granby Connecticut she says no Granby Mass
went out and jumped in my truck
and came over how long ago was this
six years something like that you've
been coming here for six years
yeah those gears haven't just transformed the
wood but the people working it crater is about
to be a married dad he's already helping take
care of his own father he won't be voyaging
with Dennett put our hearts and souls in this
together for a long time and then to to have
them step away is definitely hard but you know
I think he made the right choice for sure but
as he'd been warned Devotion to the Arabella did
make it hard for Dennett to find love all of the
time building the boat I don't think any woman was
past like two dates before they were like yeah I
don't see myself on a boat like I'm stepping out
of this one that is until he met Robin Agricola
who had already been hoping to explore the world
from a camper van I was like yeah you know I want
to like live this nomadic lifestyle and he's like
I see your van and I raise you uh 38 foot wooden
sailboat if all goes as planned they'll launch the
boat in June it's a small Cozy home though Dennis
will Captain it at least at first yeah I'm not
a sailor I don't come from that background we've
skipped over this haven't we we have yeah your
sailing background is non-existent at all yeah
never sailed I maintained the first boat I sail
on I'll be the one I built oh I sure hope you'll
like it I know you've heard that but come on
sure hope you like it I do too and I think I
will and honestly if I don't I've learned so much
building the boat I have grown so much I've met
such amazing people and connections and even if
I hated sailing I I would not regret any of this
a couple of weeks ago after our visit Steve
actually stepped back from the project to spend
more time with his mom who was just diagnosed
with an aggressive form of cancer he's trying
to get enough help so they can still finish the
vote by June and he wants to take her for a sale
well we certainly wish the Busters what a story
yeah I mean the community that was built around
it that has been built around it just the
idea and following your passions the people
and yeah and there's so many things I want
to Google why LED for Akil I wanna it used
to be heavy and dense and I really want to know
about this boat when they put it on the water
I asked him that you have nightmares about
its thinking and he said no way know-how I
am very confident in what I've made that's
great never never sailed before never built
a boat before I'm gonna build a boat and sail
let's do it money on him thank you so much bro